hi and welcome to the channel it's been
a while since i've done a talkie video
so bear with me a few of you might
remember that a couple of years ago i
released a game called perfection
[Music]
and it got great reviews i absolutely
adored watching people play the game oh
that was awesome that was really that
was really well done i was so so very
proud of it perfection had one massive
problem
and ironically that was how imperfectly
the game ran so i don't know if it's
just me but like the the controls are a
little a little weird like it's uh laggy
as what i'm trying to say looks really
nice
it's a little bit laggy though more
leggy than i thought that looks like a
potato low frame rates really bogged
down the game and left players unable to
feel fully immersed in its narrative
this place is not perfect so here i am
three years later working as an
associate technical designer and i've
decided to
take a look at perfection see where i
went wrong and how i can fix it today
i'll share with you my top 10 tips for
how i managed to get the game from
running under 20 frames per second to at
least 60 frames or more i hope it can be
helpful for you because performance is
key you can have an amazing game with
great mechanics and a really
intriguing narrative but if it doesn't
run
nobody can play and enjoy it number one
profiler the first thing that you need
to do is assess your full game's
performance to identify the areas that
need the most improvement and that's
where the profiler comes in handy the
profiler records multiple areas of your
game's performance during runtime this
allows you to pinpoint where exactly
your game is losing performance on the
left hand side there are separate
profilers for cpu gpu
memory
rendering audio physics networking and
the top half of the profiler displays
the overall usage while you're playing
your game you can open the profiler and
look for spikes in performance at
runtime and once you've identified these
spikes you can then stop at that frame
and look at the bottom half of the
profiler window which displays detailed
information from the currently selected
profiler about the current framework
data
you can inspect script code certain
assets and resources that might be
slowing it down basically the profiler
is the first thing that you should look
at when looking to optimize your game's
performance
number two multiple cameras rendering
this might be specific to me but this
was the
biggest biggest problem that was
affecting performance
i had multiple cameras rendering my
scene which meant i had
multiplied the amount of draw calls that
were even needed 120
15.
now these cameras might be used for
things that you wouldn't even expect
would be hitting performance such as
reflections for materials or a separate
camera on your player for inspecting
certain layers however if these are
always on and never turned off when you
don't need them they are still rendering
and you are still losing performance
because of that i personally had a
security camera in one of my scenes and
it was rendering all of the time
regardless of whether the player was
even within that room or not to optimize
this i severely reduced the amount of
frames per second that the camera would
render having it only render the camera
when the specified amount of frames had
elapsed within the update of a script
that i'd put on the camera itself
and because this logic was running in
the update which means every frame i put
some checks in there first to check
whether the game object itself was
actually active and also to check
whether the player themselves were
actually facing the camera
using the dot product method proved
extremely useful when trying to up my
game's performance especially if the
objects themselves had scripts that had
logic running within the updates
i will actually put a link to a video
about how to use dot products in unity
in the description below it's really
useful check it out one other thing that
i did to improve performance was use
collision boxes which would turn the
camera
game object on or off depending on
whether the player had entered or exited
the collision area
number three use layers you can use
layers for ui ray cass or specifying
what assets of a scene a camera can
actually render alongside my security
camera i was also using some water for
my terrain which had a reflective
refractive material by default the
material was set to reflect all layers
of the scene which was greatly impacting
my performance so what i did was i just
duplicated the parts of the scene that i
needed the water to reflect
and then set them to their own layer so
that the player wouldn't see them no
other cameras would see them they'd seem
like they weren't there but they were
there specifically to be reflected by
the water
this really helped performance i used
this for every single camera in my scene
as well they only rendered what i needed
them to render and what was directly in
front of them occlusion also does help
with that though but more on that later
number four
optimize your models this is where i
really struggled because i'm not a
modeler
and uh
yeah i thought i would be doing mainly
coding and scripting which i enjoy doing
and then when i realized that i probably
also need to update
my models and make them more performant
i was like
but we did it so let me tell you how
multiple me's okay so
how i noticed that my scene and my
models were probably causing me an issue
was that i opened up these stats which
is at the top right of your editor
opening this will show your frame rate
so it's really good to have open anyway
but also it shows you your tries and
verts and my tries and rats were bloody
massive just like huge numbers and they
still are to be honest because i didn't
have time to and and the knowledge
to remodel everything um so that was a
bit it was a long process but i was able
to
hide and show certain aspects of my
scene and then see how that updated the
tri and barrett's count i actually
noticed that the really small
insignificant parts of my scene were
just massive massive poly counts so i
actually just got rid of a lot of small
things such as vents and nails and stuff
that really didn't need to have these
massive poly counts for example
this small plant had
4176 faces and it was used multiple
times a lot of times throughout the
scene that's a lot of faces however if
you have a high poly model and you can't
start again or remove it because it's
important there is something that you
can do
in blender love blender so open up your
fbx in blender and what i want you to do
is find the
decimate option from here that you can
then choose to un subdivide and this
will work its magic and actually remove
faces
of course it's going to change the shape
of your model so sometimes this means
that the textures will no longer fit
but for small objects and simple objects
that maybe only have a
tiling texture it could be okay as a
rule of thumb if you didn't already know
it's really good to use a low poly mesh
in your games and then get the high poly
mesh with the detail and bake this into
a normal map that you can then use over
your low polys
it'll keep the nice crisp look
but it will keep the poly count down and
performance good you can also set up
loading but honestly i don't know too
much about that so go and look for
another video on that but loading is
good number five draw core batching
every time a model is drawn to the
screen you have to issue a draw call to
the gpu another issue that i found with
my meshes was that they were all
individual instances of the same type of
mesh for instance
every chair was its own fbx when it
could have just been duplicates of the
same mesh because of this they weren't
set up for batching because as it says
on unity's website only game objects
sharing the same material can be batched
together therefore if you want to
achieve good batching you should aim to
share materials among as many different
game objects as possible we had done
this initially because we had set up the
whole environment within maya and then
just exported it all as one fbx which
then created unique instances for each
of the parts of the fbx that were
exported
this was to save time with setting up
the environment within unity itself
but now obviously i see the drawbacks to
that which is performance it would add
to the draw calls greatly because each
mesh would be seen as a totally unique
object instead of duplicates of one
another which they technically were so
to rectify this i used one instance of
the mesh and its material on all of its
duplicates i highly recommend that you
go and do some research into batching
because it's not quite as simple as one
draw call per model there are other
factors
that
come into play here such as per pixel
lighting shadows and things like that
there are two main types of batching and
that is dynamic batching which is for
small enough meshes that transforms
their vertices on the cpu groups many
similar vertices together and draws them
in one go and there's also static
batching which combines static unmoving
game objects into big meshes and renders
them in a faster way you can go into
your player settings to enable and
disable these they both do have their
drawbacks as well so please do research
more into those for example with static
batching i did find out that the entire
of the static batch meshes would be
rendered even if just one aspect of that
batch is seen by the camera which
means you could end up having more
vertices than you need six
occlusion culling told you we'd get
there another issue that i ran into by
having multiple meshes exported as one
fbx was occlusion
occlusion didn't work properly on those
meshes because if one part was seen by
the camera then the rest of it was also
going to be rendering and occlusion is
supposed to stop that occlusion is
supposed to only render what the player
can see within their camera viewport for
example the floor was one whole fbx and
that meant that the floor was constantly
being rendered the whole floor not just
sections of it bit by bit the whole
floor even if the player was on the
other side of the building and to be
fair the floor and the ceiling didn't
have too many vertices but we also had
the same issue with
multiple objects such as all of the
cupboards for one fbx so if one cupboard
was being rendered by the camera all of
the cupboards throughout the whole
building were being rendered
now i didn't have time to go in and fix
all of that myself however setting up
occlusion properly still very much
helped my game within the static drop
down of a game object you have two
options a clue d static and a cloudera
static
are game objects that can be culled and
i made everything
a clue d
apart from my monster because that kept
popping in an ounce of occlusion and i
needed the player to see that but
everything else was a 2ds and then you
had occluders
which are game objects that can
help with the culling it can include
everything behind it so this is great
for large objects such as walls or doors
that would never be opened locked doors
because one issue that i had was that
the train was constantly being rendered
because i hadn't set up my walls to be
occluders and when they were occluders
the terrain was no longer rendered when
the player could not see them through a
wall i also set up occlusion areas to
define view volumes in the occlusion
culling system to basically tell the
system where the player was most likely
to be for me this was very simple
because i was doing everything indoors
and i have a very
linear game play
so i could easily predict where the
player was going to be it's probably
going to be harder in
an open world game or something like
that at bake time unity generates higher
precision data within the view volumes
and at run time unity performs higher
precision calculations when the camera's
position is within a view volume and if
you don't specify a view volume unity
will create you one that just
encompasses all of your cloudies and
occluders and as you can imagine that
would be massive so you definitely do
help save on performance if you set
these up manually yourself but like i
say if you have more of an open world
you might just have to let unity do its
thing you can calculate the occlusion by
going to window and occlusion culling
usually the default settings are
perfectly fine but you might want to
play around with these just to get the
effect that you'd like again i'll put
more details on occlusion in the
description below number seven lights
baking like baking was always something
that i struggled to do within this game
because it changed dynamically from day
to night which as you can imagine
drastically changed the lighting within
the scene in hindsight now i should have
found a way to seamlessly transition to
a new level that would have definitely
helped performance and there are a
couple other things that i could do
which i will tell you right now so for
now i chose to use mixed lights and
baked lights mixed lights are the best
of both worlds combining real-time
lighting with some baked lighting as
well as long as global illumination is
enabled within your scene
and then baked lights cannot change
during runtime but they significantly
help to improve performance baked lights
reduce the cost of rendering shadows as
their lights is pre-calculated so i
baked some default lights into my scene
however it was a bit too light for the
nighttime transition
luckily i had already set up a post
process effect that was put on the
player when the night time happened and
i simply made this darker so i faked it
another possible avenue that i could
have gone down for this was to create
multiple different light maps and then i
could have switched out the light maps
at runtime because every time you bake
lights you get a light map and that's
what your game uses if you can get this
light map and then switch it out using a
script then
you can get different types of lights in
the same scene so
that could have been perfect but yeah i
didn't do that
i just think i ran out of patience to be
honest with you i also use light probes
to improve the quality of lighting on
dynamic objects within my scene light
probes are positions in the scene where
light is measured during the bake and
then this information can be used during
runtime to approximate indirect light
values from the nearest light probe when
it hits a dynamic game object overall
light baking is a very complex and
useful tool especially for improving
your games look and performance and i
will admit to not yet fully
understanding it however i will put in
the description a video about light maps
that i found very informative
number eight optimizing your code
ultimately every script is different and
there will be endless tips on how to
optimize your c sharp so i'll just focus
on the main points surprise surprise the
update we spoke about this a little bit
earlier but i definitely need to talk to
you about it in more detail every piece
of code in the update gets run every
single frame of your game hence why in
the security camera script that i showed
you earlier i had multiple checks before
running any logic that was put in my
update putting code into the update
without thinking about it is quite a
rookie move because when you first learn
about it it seems pretty logical i mean
if you have code in the update and it's
always running then it's easier to debug
whether it's working correctly and you
don't have to worry about whether it's
going to be triggered or not however
when optimizing you really need to ask
yourself does this logic need to be ran
every single frame if it's the character
movement probably yes
if it's a door opening and closing
probably not
and if it is not then think about
whether it can be put in its own
function that is triggered only when
it's needed simply put the less amount
of code in the update the more
performant your scripts will be
[Music]
for example i had a script that was
checking for certain actions to be done
by the player this would then increment
an integer variable called observant
this check was being done in a separate
script to the one that was managing the
player interactions and it was checking
whether the player was inspecting every
single frame whenever the player had
inspected an object it would then return
true and then increment plus one to the
observant integer number there was no
real need for this separate script to
have logic in its update to check
whether the player was interacting to
make this more performant i made the
observant variable global so that it
could be easily accessed by other
scripts and then i simply added the
increment logic into the interaction
script itself so that when a player
interacted with something it also then
incremented that global
observant integer variable no more
checks in the update were needed it
simply said player interacts update this
variable
and that was that it's all about
breaking down the logic and finding the
most direct route to get the results
that you need if you need code to run
frequently but not necessarily all of
the time then perhaps look into
co-routines i use these for short
lasting events and animations such as
lights flickering on and off and also ui
fading in and fading out in between
screen loading times however they do
have their own drawbacks as they can be
difficult to debug and they do create
garbage again i will put a link down to
a wonderful blog all about updates and
how to keep them performant in the
description below a function to look out
for this time is find game object i had
used this function a lot when i was
first starting out in game dev and i
thought i was really smart at the time
it saved me the time of having to
manually assign all of the relationships
between the assets because i could just
get the game to do it for me which is
great right
no
the game needs to be handling things
that should run the game not stuff that
you should be manually setting up
yourself come on you're lazy dane game
dev dane
i ended up using find game object in so
many of my scripts and i had to
slash it out just slash it out and
manually assign stuff because
that helped performance the
the game could then focus on running the
game instead of finding everything and
setting it up correctly which i should
have done beforehand when you call this
function the game has to manually loop
through all of the game objects that are
currently in the scene to find the one
that matches your name
that's
potentially
so so so many game objects and as you
can imagine if you have this happening
all at the same time over multiple
scripts it's definitely going to affect
performance to manually assign them you
can create a public variable and then
select the appropriate game object or
whatever that whatever that it is and
assign the correct one to it within the
inspector manually assigning though will
only work on game objects that are
already in the scene so if you're
planning on spawning something during
runtime then you might need to use this
or perhaps use more specific versions of
this i know there is fine game objects
with tag and things like that so
that will probably be better to use than
just the generic find game object and if
you're unsure whether you'll need them
then just put a check beforehand just
see whether the relationship has already
been established and if not then you can
find the game object i often did this
with things like my camera just in case
for some reason i would lose reference
to my camera because i was switching
cameras quite often so i would say yeah
if camera equals null
then find the main camera
lastly turn off scripts when they're not
needed you can do this like i explained
earlier with the collision collisions
are great well i don't that's how i do
it it's probably not a great way if you
know a better way than to turn off
things via collision let me know because
i've just had collisions everywhere
saying yeah the player is nowhere near
this thing so turn it off and don't do
all the things so
maybe you know a better way
tell me please
optimize your game object components
unity offers many components that define
the behaviors of the game object which
really makes our lives so much easier we
don't have to code every tiny detail
which is great especially for physics
it's great you simply select a game
object and add a new component in the
inspector window and ta-da your game
object now has physics ui collision or
so much more
so much variety however
some of these components are way more
performance expensive than others so do
make sure you're using the correct ones
for your needs don't do what i did and
just use mesh colliders on everything
because it's so much easier you're lazy
game death
oh man this is me berating my younger
self now isn't it mesh colliders have a
much higher performance impact than box
colliders or any other type of colliders
so really use them sparingly it seems
like the best collision to use because
it will create collision that perfectly
matches your geo however it will be
checking for collision against
potentially every single face of your
mesh
which is probably not needed
if you need to create collision that
does
match a certain shape maybe a rectangle
or something you can use multiple
collisions you can use two box
collisions to create that
right angle is that what i just said
something like that all you have to do
is create multiple primitive collisions
and then change their scale and location
to create the collision
shape that you need for your geo and if
you're anything like me you'll get
really excited about the thought of
anything in your game having the ability
to use physics
and you'll put rigid bodies
everywhere when they're not needed as
you can imagine rigid bodies use the
inbuilt physics system that unity has
and it does affect performance
it will definitely
impact performance if you have a rigid
body that is also usually a mesh
collider
which a lot a lot of my game objects had
that combination and it wasn't good so
i actually just removed all the rigid
bodies from my game apart from on moving
objects such as the player and the
monster i had a misunderstanding of how
the rigid body worked i thought it
needed to be put on anything that could
be movable
and this isn't necessarily true because
i had objects that could be examined and
then
they were brought up to the camera's
face
and then the player could use their
mouse to basically just turn it around
have a little look at it look at all the
details and nice things that
doesn't use physics that doesn't need a
rigid body that was all done by script
so actually i could just remove all of
these rigid bodies and it really did
help save performance 10
adjustable quality settings finally give
the player some control over the game's
performance themselves allow them to
adjust the quality settings at runtime
you might be testing your game and it
runs perfectly fine in your beasty in pc
but then if someone really wants to play
your game and all they have is a crappy
laptop that their dad bought them five
years ago for christmas
they have no way of changing the quality
and trying to improve the performance
and then they can't enjoy your game this
is more simple than you might think
you can
rename or add new quality settings under
edit project settings and quality all
you have to do is create a drop down
menu in your game with the same amount
of
quality levels as what's in your project
settings and then call set quality level
on drop down value changed i watched
this tutorial by brachis i'm sure a lot
of you if you watch a lot of game dare
tutorials will know who he is wonderful
please watch that if you'd like to find
out more about how to create a settings
menu in unity description down below
link down below in description okay
here's the bonus one for you
number 11 there will be bugs don't panic
when working with a game that wasn't
built with performance or longevity in
mind there will come a time
where fixing one bug will just start to
create more so when i began improving
this
game i had grand visions of including
new sections to it new levels
adding new mechanics and features
and that simply just was not attainable
even though i was able to add one new
feature of a webcam
and update some of the designs on
certain aspects such as the doors
i
had to ultimately abandon my
hopes and dreams of including much more
content to the game itself and after i
had worked my little butt off for three
weeks
updating this game's performance and
released it letting people know about it
on social media
i
then realized that there was a pc
specific game breaking bug
and not gonna lie i was
so
[Music]
tired
i think i just i'd worked really hard
and then to find out that the game
couldn't even be completed by some
people
was just a kind of kick in the face to
make matters worse because it was pc
specific it didn't happen on my pc so i
had to
give the potential fixed builds to
someone whose pc
did have the bug it took longer to do
that one bug than to update the
performance of the whole game it was
infuriating but
that is game development for you it's a
fickle process but it is challenging and
it is really rewarding i can safely say
that perfection is one of the most
proudest achievements that i've had so
far
and that is simply because game dev
offers so much it offers me so much to
learn it offers
players so much to become immersed in
it's the only entertainment platform
that can really engage with its audience
in ways that no others can
and i find that really rewarding but of
course game dev is huge there's so many
aspects to it there's so much to learn
there's so much that i still don't know
and i'm sure there's so much that you
don't know especially if you clicked on
this video so let's learn together
that's also what i love about the game
dev community if there's something that
i have missed out in this video that you
know about please write it in the
comments or if there's something that
you want to expand on that i have talked
about
write it there too
hey if i'm wrong on something call me
out on that
there's still so much that i want to
learn
and i just hope that by sharing what i
learn along the way with you that it
will also
help you and your game dev journey as
well with that all being said please
check out perfection and check out the
performance updates all exciting stuff
also some new features in there as well
some new content to check out so
i would
love it if you could check out the game
and just tell me what you think of it
any feedback good or bad constructive
you know just
yes please thank you
okay i don't know why i'm like so
nervous now anyway it's been nice to
chat with you again it's been a long
time i will see you very soon and have a
lovely day or evening bye thank you so
much to all my patreons for all your
support i really appreciate you so much
thanks to to mitchu bart lee clark louis
frost gaming with malachi 79 zomelanovic
mantas navigates colin williams ab196
andy bonte frares sayed and thomas
graham jury you are awesome
he's going to jump out at me i want to
escape how do i go for oh that's me
oh god